♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
If it is alright with you,
I'm just gonna jump
right into it.
We talked about how
Justin Bieber
was gonna have his own
Justin Bieber-inspired
doughnut holes
at Tim Horton's,
the Canadian doughnut shop.
I was told by many
of our Canadian viewers
that in Canada, they are not
called doughnut holes.
They are called Timbits.
Interesting --
Timbit has another meaning.
It is a tidbit
not interesting enough
to share.
[ Laughter ]
Aisling Bea, wonderful actress,
was here.
And she talked about how
Dustin the Turkey,
a turkey puppet,
actually was the entry
for Ireland
in the Eurovision Song Contest
in 2008.
I said, "How did he do?
Did he win?"
She said, "No,
he was eliminated."
And I joked,
"Well, I'm sure he finished --
he was the top-finishing
turkey."
He was not.
Turkey was.
[ Laughter ]
We had a joke in yesterday's
monologue about a manger.
We referred to a manger
as if it was a building.
A manger is not a building.
It is a trough.
Where they feed animals.
And, interesting --
I did some research --
They came up with
the word manger
because trough
didn't sound good in carols.
[ Laughter ]
Like, when it was like,
"Away in a trough,"
like immediately,
people were like, "Ugh."
Talked about I was feeling bad,
and when I feel bad,
my friend Andy Samberg
has a homeopathic cure.
And I called him up and he did
his Robert Smith impression.
A lot of people said
that's not --
"What you described is not
homeopathic medicine."
The way homeopathic
medicine works
is it doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
I guess you dilute --
you need to dilute
the thing that's
making you sick.
You take a very small
dose of that
to supposedly make you better.
I will say --
I love him --
Andy's Robert Smith impression
was pretty diluted.
[ Laughter ]
I've tried to get him...
Hate to say it --
I've tried to get him to go
to impression camp.
He won't go.
And it only works
if he wants to go.
Talked about --
Again, I think this is week four
of talking about
"Shoemaker and the Elves."
And at first, I was told --
I referred to it as a fable.
"Shoemaker and the Elves"
is the story about the elves
who are paid
to write jokes here.
When they do a bad job,
Shoemaker throws them
out the window.
And I called it a fable,
and people said no,
a fable needs a moral,
and I said the moral is
don't mess with Mike Shoemaker.
And then another person said,
"Oh, fables have to
have animals,
and elves aren't animals."
But I do realize
where I made my mistake,
which is when Shoemaker squeezes
them out the window,
he does say, "Enjoy your flight,
ya [bleep] animal!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, sometimes history
creeps its way into Corrections,
and we learned a lot
about defenestration,
which is the act of throwing
somebody out a window.
And it happens a lot in Prague.
The most famous ones
happen in Prague.
If you look up defenestrations,
it's gonna take you
right to the defenestrations
of Prague.
There are three main
defenestrations in Prague --
1419, 1483, 1618.
Big gap between the last two.
They went from 1483 to 1618
without a defenestration.
People probably --
at that point,
probably thought they were safe.
That the crime wave
of defenestration was over.
Then next thing you know,
go to the tower of your castle
and just chucked out,
just --
[ Laughs ]
...just DJ Jazzy Jeff'ed
out the window.
[ Laughter ]
But this is
the fascinating thing.
The third of the defenestrations
is known as the Second
Defenestration of Prague,
because I guess the second one,
the one that happened in 1483,
is not considered
a significant defenestration.
Must have been a real blow
to the families...
[ Laughter ]
...who got chucked
out the window
for the second defenestration.
When the Prague cops showed up
to the house,
told them, you know, "Your loved
one was tossed out a window,"
and they said, "Well...
at least he'll always
be remembered
as being a victim of the second
defenestration of Prague."
And the cops were like,
"Ehhh..."
[ Laughter ]
"We might save the name."
I also said it started
the Thirty Year War.
It's the Thirty Years' War.
The Thirty Year War --
8 1/2 months.
We mentioned seagulls.
And we showed a photo of this.
And a couple people said,
"That is not a seagull.
That is a silver gull."
And obviously,
I was pretty upset
that Graphics would
do me like that.
Feels like it'd be pretty easy
to find a photo of a seagull
instead of a very rare
silver gull from Australia.
And you know what you call me
when I think Graphics
is gonna give me the right bird?
Gullible.
Baze.
[ Laughter ]
Why'd you tell me...
that would work?
We talked about
the Attenborough brothers.
I thought they were the same.
Richard and David.
David, the naturalist;
Richard --
I referred to Richard the actor.
He was in "Jurassic Park."
A lot of people said I
overlooked his directing career.
And I apologize
to Richard Attenborough.
"Gandhi."
"Chaplin."
"A Chorus Line."
That one's a bridge too far.
[ Laughter ]
Did you get it?
[ Sing-song voice ]
I really hope you get it.
[ Laughter ]
I said that --
[ Laughs ]
I basically said there was some
tension between the brothers
because, you know, David did
all these documentaries,
and does all these
documentaries,
about the modern natural world,
and then, you know,
Richard got this big part
in "Jurassic Park"
and wouldn't let David,
you know, help with it,
because it's about dinosaurs.
But then people said, "Yeah,
but actually, David has done,
you know, multiple documentaries
about dinosaurs, as well."
So it was probably
even more awkward,
you know,
when Richard was like --
[ Cockney accent ]
"Oi, David!
Doin' a new Spielberg.
Yeah, got a part in the new
Spielberg, don't I, David?
It's about dinosaurs."
And David was like --
[ Cockney accent] "Oh, Dickie, I
know a fair bit about dinosaurs.
You wanna put in a good word
for me?
Would love to work
on the new Spielberg."
And he's like,
"Oh, I'm sorry, David.
It's a blockbuster, innit?"
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, it's a blockbuster.
Nah, Steve thinks your
documentaries are a bit slow."
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice ]
Then their brother John came in.
He's like, "Oi!"
Now, here's the thing,
for the rest of this bit.
For the rest of this bit,
you need to know a key fact.
There were three
Attenborough brothers.
The ones we've been talking
about -- Richard, David --
knighted.
John -- not knighted.
[ Cockney accent ]
"Oi! Dickie! David!
Supper's ready."
"Oi! What'd you call us?!
I think there's a word missin'
in front of our name, John."
"Am I really gonna
have to do this?"
"That's right, you are."
"Sir Dickie, Sir David,
dinner's ready."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I guess people
said, "You know, actually" --
And again, I know
that's not how they talk.
They went to a boys school
in Leicester,
and someone said
they should actually have
a Leicester accent, but um...
I would hate to see Seth Meyers
try a Leicester accent."
'Cause I guess it's a hard --
in their head, they perceive it
as a hard accent.
I do a very good
Leicester accent.
[ As Lester Holt ]
Welcome to "NBC Nightly News."
[ Laughter ]
Whoever's from Leicester
is gonna love that one.
[ Laughter ]
I confused windmills
and wind turbines.
A lot of you were angry
about that.
Um...
If I was -- If I was building
windmills or wind turbines,
I would build it next
to a jackal's house
'cause you guys blow so hard.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Someone sent a comment --
And, you know, again,
we've established that, uh...
who you are, jackals,
but I want to finish
with this comment.
"A few years ago, I went to an
audience with David Attenborough
in Australia, and the audience
were able to put in questions.
My friend's question was picked,
and he asked,
'If you could be
in Jurassic Park,
what would you want
to see first?'
And he said,
'The first thing would be
to go see my brother Richard.'
This was after Richard
had passed away.
Just a lovely, lovely,
wonderful man."
Every time I think
the only way
jackals can make me feel
is frustrated,
you write something beautiful
like that.
Thank you for sharing it.
This has been Corrections.
See me next week.